doja cat dm's this kid will from uh
stranger things saying yo set me up with
your boy
the punk kid from stranger things yeah
he posts it on the internet and posts
the whole screenshot she's like he's
like wow this is so funny
dojo cat is trying to smash dude yeah
she gets pissed off and it's like yo
this kid's a snake leaked my dms because
she got a man probably
oh
so she was doing foul [ __ ]
that's what i assume oh i thought it's
because she caught a lot of heat that
she's dating white boys
that's
black twitter that's right that could be
it
yeah uh-huh by the way
this is embarrassing
why are you friends with a 17 year old
that's the embarrassing thing to me
going through a 17 year old to get the
older dude
i mean yes dm also like call your agent
your agent is going to be able to
connect you to him like you wanted to dm
the stranger things kid you want to talk
to the stranger things kid like you're
watching the show
there's nothing wrong with that that's
fine but why didn't she just dm herself
why should she be a man what does she
say that dude doesn't have instagram or
something like that i think that's
that's but then he did she just couldn't
find it
she goes can you tell joseph to hit me
up no wait does he have a girlfriend lol
sliding his dm sign i don't know his ig
or twitter he doesn't have a dm to slide
why are you having a conversation with a
guy who calls you ma'am
i mean like this is a 17 year old kid oh
he said ma'am yeah look right here man
ma'am
get out of here and she mad at him this
is embarrassing for you it might be the
ma'am you know yeah yeah the ma'am in
the post that's crazy
yeah
but also it's corny of him why'd you
why'd you leave that 17 you don't know
no better you should never leak dms
never leak private [ __ ] i don't care if
it's nudes or a private conversation
yeah you don't know what somebody's more
embarrassed about we put all this value
on nudes but some people might be way
more comfortable with their news being
out there than a private conversation
sure so yeah you this he should go to
jail he should be shot in his [ __ ]
head
whatever happens samia khalifa should
happen to him a hundred percent whatever
he's seventeen it's different rules
put him in juvie okay social media
fighting slipping on semen yeah slipping
all these scenes you know what i mean
like have him out there fighting
slipping on a scene okay all right like
that's some real [ __ ] yeah you don't
know what rikers is like
yeah yeah you never run time akash you
you do some time you out there dude
wants to fight you you in the showers
seaming everywhere slipping on it
that's something you never experience
that's why they don't tell you you fall
on the semen now you're sitting and
seeing now you're sitting and seeing
seam is seeping up your butt cheeks and
butthole yeah yeah now you're pregnant
now your kid's gay yeah
think about that oh that's how they're
made you're dead you've never done time
yes bro if you did time you would know
okay yes [ __ ] what did you do what'd
you think again what'd you do i snuffed
somebody that got you on rikers
no when i was in rikers oh okay i
snuffed somebody yeah slipped lick the
floor clean
yo it is what it is bro i said to myself
i was like i ain't slipping on no semen
for
this guy wanted to fight with me he's
like he's like yo we might slip on steam
and i'm like i ain't slipping on those
semen
slurped it up
had all the grip
had all the grips did you win the fight
at least say what you were in the fight
i'm i was cramping because i was so full
you can't exercise after you eat so
quickly
jigglypuff over here
you eat that much calories you can't
exercise right there yeah you know what
i mean i probably ate about a good two
billion kids
jeez i was eating two those are tough
kids too those are criminals kids yeah
[ __ ] was going crazy gang
fights in my tummy
throwing up different sets that's crazy
did you get impregnated say again did
you get impregnated i told you i got
pregnant yeah i got scooped bro i got an
emotion
yeah i got into motion dude and that's
why i'm so pro female's choice
man's choice say what and male's choice
to get in a smartphone pro pregnant
person choice i was pro-pregnant
person's choice yeah yo abortion is
nothing to joke around about yeah
serious al for real dude
yeah i gave myself it
how you do that say again how you do
that how did i give myself an abortion
yeah well there's only one way you can
do it yeah yeah what is it wire hanger
no no dude that's gross crazy dude i've
seen disgusting no when i was playing
basketball and i just hit a shot and my
boy jumped and i jumped to do that like
uh yeah
yeah like high five thing yeah oh wow
that seems pretty easy to be honest he's
very easy but has anyone ever done that
he's never lost a child has anyone ever
done that in sports in real life
say what like the chess bump in sports
like i've never seen that happen in real
life ever
like you're playing basketball your boy
and you make a shot and you like chest
bump in the air mark you watch soccer
yeah you don't watch real special if you
watch a real sport has it never happened
in basketball ever yes bro all the time
a chest bump where your nose is touched
no that [ __ ] is such a nose that's the
weirdest way you can make it less weird
that's the weirdest celebration of
sports you go and you put your titties
on some other dude and you jump in the
air i don't believe in it and i've also
never seen it it never happens with
football never happens in basketball it
doesn't happen in soccer no it doesn't
happen that's not how they celebrate
they slide on their knees like
the ground's full of semen is that what
they do they're like about to suck dick
they're so excited they run they slide
their knees and they just hope that
they're sliding their belly sometimes
just pulling andrew schultz in a riker's
prison yeah exactly he's never on my
belly bro how you lick say what hands
i did